organizations that are developing ever
larger scale out applications will leave
no stone unturned in their search for a
compute platform that meets their needs
for example let's say you're building a
java application or a web server for an
iot use case that analyzes live video
data from warehouse floors to identify
labor quality issues this brings the
challenges of achieving scale out high
performance computing power while
keeping costs down
for many that means looking into the arm
architecture arm-based chips are already
ubiquitous in mobile devices and iot use
cases like smart cars drones and more
this is possible because arm-based
processors run at consistently high
frequencies and are built with large
low-latency private caches providing
high performance computing power while
having low power consumption sounds
amazing right but you might not know
that arm native processors have proven
themselves for super computing workloads
and are increasingly seen as a viable
option for the next generation of scale
out cloud native workloads yeah we're
talking compute intensive workloads like
media transcoding desktop laptop server
machine devices and high performance
computing used in even some of the
fastest supercomputers in the world and
when deployed in the cloud they can
enable users to scale linearly provide
predictable performance and provide the
highest density of cores at a lower
price point
the good news is arm has arrived at
google cloud last year we added tau vms
to compute engine offering a new family
of vms optimized for cost-effective
performance for scale-out workloads
we're now announcing our first vm family
based on the arm architecture tau t2a
powered by ampere ultra arm-based
processors t2a vms deliver exceptional
single threaded performance at a
compelling price
tau t2a vms come in multiple pre-defined
vm shapes with up to 48 vcpus per vm and
4 gigabytes of memory per vcpu they
offer up to 32 gigabits per second
networking bandwidth and a wide range of
network attached storage options making
tau t2a vms ideal for scale out
workloads including web servers
containerized microservices data logging
processing media trends coding and large
scale out java applications the key win
here is the integration with the google
cloud ecosystem tau t2a vms support most
popular linux operating systems such as
red hat enterprise linux scent os ubuntu
and rocky linux
in addition t2a vms also support
container optimized os to bring up
docker containers quickly efficiently
and securely if you already have an
existing arm workload switching to the
new t2a vms follows the same process you
already use to manage your google
compute engine vms
it's easy to move between arm and x86
architectures for most applications and
in fact most web applications written in
java javascript c-sharp python ruby etc
don't even need to recompile and most go
programs should work after a recompile
if you run your applications in
containers and orchestrate them using
kubernetes you might want to check out
what's new in google kubernetes engine
gke users will be able to incorporate
t2a vm node pools into their clusters
you can use arm nodes in gke and the new
manage mode gke autopilot to explore how
you can develop test and deploy your
containers on the arm architecture our
newly launched batch service supports
t2a now you can run batch jobs on t2a
instances to optimize your cost of
running workloads and for streaming
analytics and batch processing you can
now use t2a vms with your data flow
workloads
stay tuned as we add t2a support for
more google cloud services later this
year please note that this initial
offering has a few limitations for
example t2a vms don't currently offer
high cpu or high mem configs custom
machine types local ssds or gpu support
but the feature set will change in the
future generations so please be sure to
take a look at the documentation google
cloud customers and developers can now
have the option of choosing an empire
ultra cloud native processor to test
develop and run existing workloads less
expensively or build new applications
with better economics and performance it
gives you more optionality and have
cost-effective alternatives to
traditional x86 servers
there are more arm chips rolling out in
the future and features will be added
over time so now is a pretty good time
to go and explore this offering and see
how it can help you save a little bit of
money to learn more head over to the
links in the description for more
information about the new arm vms and be
sure to like and subscribe to stay up to
date with the latest and greatest from
the google cloud tech channel